who is the most qualified Republican to
take on president Underwood in 2016
you mean Hillary Clinton so it was crazy
about house of cards I've been up since
3:00 a.m. watching it I literally didn't
sleep well CPAC is a really important
event I mean if you think about the
people that are assembled here but they
really care about is who's gonna be the
next president of the United States
they're really thinking about the the
they're there they're thinking about the
issues excuse me they're thinking about
the issues that are really important in
the country and these are serious issues
you know their lives are at stake
overseas the yeah what's going on
what what are you doing
I know and I don't have time to watch
and I'm a binge watcher oh my god I
can't do it once a week last year I just
watched the whole thing trade through on
Valentine's so long
I don't know why your priorities are you
want to like watch them what do you do
are you watching it right infront of my
face I gotta tell you what happens okay
don't tell me don't tell me maybe we
could watch it don't tell me I don't
want you I just watch it now I did wait
five minutes we can just okay okay okay
I don't have a lot of time it's so
unfair that seatback is happening right
now right this is ridiculous
they're trying to elect a president
United States well why would I know this
on the day that this comes out six
thousand rooms you don't have any
viewing parties setup or anything for
people who want to watch house apart so
I remember the last when he knocks the
desk bang bang look they just try it
okay
alright give it a shot one minute with
me all right oh my god there we go I am
watching house of cards with fire
theater it's amazing how spooky that
fast motion thing gets you know I'm
laughing yeah I mean it's spooky see oh
I know I'm sorry - Rob mr. chairman
you're late for Jeb Bush your speech you
gotta go it's open it doesn't pitch fine